deux équipes evinoises pour une place en
finale de la Coupe de Paris le FC
Mantois qui évolue en R1 recevait ce
dimanche hardricour une équipe de R3 dès
le coup d'envoi les deux divisions ne se
font pas ressentir malgré quelques
situations pour les joueurs locaux le
score à la pose et de 0 à 0 en football
je suis pas sûr qu'on ait pris des
leçons au contraire on a fait le jeu
habituel c'est on joue au foot on a bien
démarré le match maintenant on n'a pas
su concrétiser les peu d'opportunités
offensives qu'on a eu et après bah ils
ont ils ont joué kramment de leur chance
en travaillant avec un blog bas au
retour des vestiaires même scénario le
FC Mantois domine mais n'arrive pas à
être vraiment dangereux devant le but la
délivrance arrivera finalement toute fin
de match sur ce coup franc un à zéro
un très court pousse mais n'arrivera pas
à revenir le FC Mantois étant final bah
ça se joue sur un coup de pied arrêté
donc voilà c'est ça aurait pu être de
l'autre côté aussi donc c'est un détail
je trouve que c'est un détail et que en
tout cas je les félicite parce qu'ils
ont ils ont joué avec leurs atouts et
ils nous ont mis en difficulté tout
simplement et bah déception parce que
franchement on a fait pratiquement jeu
égal avec une équipe que une très très
bonne équipe de R1 qui qui va remonter
en m3 parce que c'est au moins sa place
si ce n'est plus donc on est content en
plus à se jouer sur sur peu de choses
sur un détail le FC Mantois connaîtra
son adversaire le 5 mars prochain il
s'agira de Vincennes de
Neuilly-sur-Marne ou de Paris 15